c'est l'heure du petit déjeuner pour les
vaches laitières de la ferme de grignon
au menu des cultures fourragères
chez nous la ration est composé en base
on va dire c'est de l'ensilage de maïs
donc c'est à peu près un tiers de 1/3 du
mélange qu'une plante riche en énergie
mais assez pauvre en protéines on met de
la luzerne aussi il ya beaucoup de
luzerne chez nous c'est un gros quart de
la ration herbe luzerne maïs les
fourrages sont stockés toute l'année à
l'extérieur la préparation et le mélange
des ingrédients sont minutieux on a une
tablette numérique sur le sur le
tracteur qui n'oublie la quantité à m
parent par aliments par lot de vaches et
dès qu'on atteint la quantité mon arrêt
de 340 kg la mixture est ensuite
distribuée aux bêtes elles en consomment
près de 23 kg par jour une quantité
nécessaire pour la production du lait
des vaches
aucun changement dans le traitement des
animaux de la ferme même en hiver les
vaches ont rarement froid en fait leur
température idéale ces cinq opérations
extérieures
donc c'est pour ça que voyez que le
bâtiment là est très ouvert parce que
finalement le rumen fait beaucoup de
chaleur et elle cherche à se débarrasser
quelque part de cette chaleur
du côté des céréales la récolte 2010 est
est jugée précoce mais de qualité pour
l'hiver la ferme de grignon a déjà
planté du colza spécifique pour la
saison le colza pour l'instant on n'est
pas très développé puis après ça
continue à se développer pour son humour
si refaire plus de feuilles avant
l'hiver il va entrer en dormance pour
l'hiver et puis repartira au printemps
est assez rapidement ici partir de fin
mars début avril on peut commencer à
voir les premières fleurs de colza avec
une bonne récolte du colza en 2017
malgré quelques doutes
la ferme de grignon espère faire aussi
bien en 2018